buh-bah just go up my pretend like
you're bout to tossin just going into
slam dunk Oh baby
you just got Bobby tench open what's up
guys I'm master and this is junior
bleacher report
we're here at Las Vegas summer league at
the beer house at the park we're to talk
some locals to figure out what's really
poppin here in Vegas the only catches
that boab on Myon of itch and Tobias
Harris are gonna be feeding us all of
our questions whenever they tell us we
got a do man my friend I hope somebody
kick who's this
you're gonna go up to those two guys
play and interview them ask them what
they feel about the new Las Vegas
professional basketball team and of them
signing bobba how do you feel about the
new las vegas basketball team signing
buh ba mi olivet where we're from Canada
right so when it comes to the NBA the
NHL rules supreme sure what about the
rappers then they should have done
better in the playoffs but hopefully
next year or their coaching change yes
what does he think about LeBron James we
want to the Raptors what do you think
about LeBron James go to the Raptors I
mean just breaking news that came in
like 15 minutes ago
Oh LeBron James to a Raptors means
championships right so now you're an NBA
fan oh now now you're an NBA fan you're
an aspirin
they're winning championships and we're
on James equals championship keep saying
I'm so pumped up right now and really
good fit keep saying it so so pumped up
just like really pumped up tell them
you're a magician okay you're gonna get
a dollar I don't have a dollar once you
get the I'd like to tell you guys that
I'm behind you I loved it really yeah
can you go get some yeah please I got a
table there what's your name Nico Thomas
under Nico take all three and just start
walking take all three get them right
back
so me and June already hit the streets
of Vegas but now let's see what Bob on
Tobias there we go aha I hold it down
telling name five players they have five
players that play that play and we
believe worst Honor we believe worst
oh you won't hit me with the we believe
I thought she was gonna go you know a
little further funny cuz I was gonna hit
that one
okay Davis Davis Oh Davis who what wow
this is honestly I'm gonna camera I'm
gonna camera dogs nothing let's go let's
go a little further back let's go hard
away far away from my error McMullen
first off first off it's not Nick mall
okay how you say Chris mother now first
I just say I was a die-hard though
because you know the Warriors fan but
you from the Bay Area
let me see you at this face let me see
your face hey let's play together -
birds - okay tell me I can go first and
then just keep blocking every side all
right you guys go further because I
start first
yes
come on recover let's go you gotta get
in here
no now don't talk that's good good job
wait watch out because I don't want you
Blanca Baba just go up well Oakland
pretending about to toss and just go
into slam-dunk
[Music]
Oh
you gotta call me baby you just got
Bobby I'm Bobby I'm Toby
we're here with Beach report we had a
great time one wish you guys are a great
summer amazing time great experience
thank you guys hey my man publication